free who are you wearing tonight
[Applause]
honey you and I tell you you would
answer them
ASAP have not been messing around or
maybe you have I don't know
congratulations you got here right how
was the second pregnancy how are they
different from the first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea everything's
different but I'm enjoying it I'm
enjoying it I feel good I feel energetic
thank you so much and it looks like that
little guy of yours is pretty energetic
and so happy what Mom does is are you
I'm in love I'm obsessed and I don't
even feel guilty about it
life is very busy right now you've got
obviously your beautiful growing family
you've got the new Smurf movie but honey
when we're gonna work our nine into the
mixes
[Music]
you know what when I do when I'm ready
yeah I'm coming straight to you first
you better I I have that is the promise
[Music]
yes
ring what is this costume you're rocking
tonight what is this look ASAP if we
won't explain it to me please give us
some insight to this look
piece called Lagerfeld you know this is
just tradition to him and I just wanted
to pay homage the right way a little bit
of kittens you know
let's discover here but that's from my
ladies
she has a little man doing and growing
big beautiful happy baby thank you for
asking and congratulations on baby
and not mess around mama
Ray
congratulations sis
we're so happy Mom and Dad finally made
it
[Music]
foreign